Welcome back everyone marvel's been filming loki
season two episodes they just released a first
look at a couple big scenes they're filming
in an episode with a bunch of easter eggs for
other current stuff that's happening in the mcu so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i'll be doing episode videos for season two just
like i did for loki's season one and obviously big
coincidence now thor love and thunder is hitting
theaters as we speak we're doing a giveaway for
imax tickets for the movie all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just post all your
theories about what's going on during loki season
2 on the video i'll talk about what's going on
in all these brand new loki season 2 scenes that
they're filming first then later in the video i'll
explain the connection to thor love and thunder
because obviously you talk about loki you also
want to talk about thor as well in some of what's
going on in the loki scenes that they're filming
for season 2 is related to the thor comics but
what's going on in this scene that they're filming
right now is that our main loki from season one is
with mobius and they're in 1970s london attending
a movie premiere and the movie that they're seeing
is a huge easter egg like the movie itself and
all the names the actors the posters for the movie
in universe are a bunch of easter eggs and
there are a couple other funny easter eggs
for other movies inside the mcu like that's a
big thing now in marvel after avengers end game
like you see a bunch of fake movie posters and
movies that they made but they themselves are a
bunch of easter eggs and references for things
that happen in the mcu really good example is
that there's movie posters for one of kingo's old
movies that he starred in during the 1970s when he
was pretending to be his great great grandfather
and they just literally referenced that during the
miss marvel episodes in the past couple of weeks
because her family's from pakistan originally so
her parents and like their older circle of friends
and extended family are huge fans of the person
that they're calling kingo senior who they in the
mcu think is one of these ancestors of kingos like
his great great grandfather his great-grandfather
grandfather father and then kingo himself like
they all believe the lie that it's all different
members of his family when really it's just kingo
pretending to be his different descendants along
the years we actually know which kingo movie it is
so i'll explain those easter eggs when we get to
that part but remember everything that's happening
in this scene is taking place after r loki came
back to the rebooted and changed timeline in the
tv8 because the negative effects of her killing
he who remains kang at the end of time had already
taken effect so the timeline rebooted but because
the second kang multiverse war had started it had
played out a little bit differently that's why
we saw this different version of kang being in
charge of this version of the tva so it's like
the timeline has changed a bunch and this other
kang has just orchestrated the tva the way that he
wants to as opposed to the way that he who remains
wanted to orchestrate the tva but i think the
idea with this new version of kang is that he's
supposed to be way worse because that was what he
who remains was talking about like if you think
that i'm bad wait till you meet my variants and
cut to the end of the episode we meet one of his
variants but that's why this version of mobius and
hunter b15 didn't know who our loki was when he
ran up to them talking about he who remains like
wait a minute who are you why do you know all this
stuff who's this he who remains person that you're
talking about so the beginning of season two they
kind of have to go through those similar steps
where they try to arrest him and then he has to
convince them that he's telling the truth like no
no no there's this person orchestrating everything
kang is lying to you in the movie zaniak is
a huge easter egg because zaniak is an actual
marvel character from the comics but in the marvel
universe zaniac was kind of like the essence or
the spirit of a serial killer who would possess
different people's bodies across time using
supernatural means the reason why they're using
him on the loki series is because he appeared
for the first time in the thor comics and this
is loki so obviously thor connection you get it
but the star of the movie brad wolfe is another
easter egg because in the marvel universe in the
comics he was just a regular actor who signed
on to play a fictional version of the zaniac
character in a movie inside the marvel comics but
then when he was dressed like the zaniac character
they started filming the movie doing his scenes
he had an accident and was mutated into the actual
zaniac character possessed by a spirit turned into
a killer tried to kill a bunch of the crew members
until thor stopped him and they threw him in an
insane asylum so if you remember the guardians
of the galaxy 2 deleted scenes with a wonder man
character played by nathan fillion like he played
a version of that character in the universe but
he was an actor pretending to be these different
characters so they're kind of doing the same
thing it's the same energy with this zaniak movie
but basically during loki season two it
seems like they're doing a version of that
zaniak origin story except when the actor gets
turned into the real xenia going crazy trying to
kill a bunch of people it's loki who stops
them from killing everyone instead of thor
and if you zoom in enhance on the movie poster
credits here for all the other actors names
the production crew members names the production
company is listed as a goodman production that's a
huge easter egg for the origin of the marvel comic
book company itself originally the company was
owned by martin goodman who owned timely comics
that was the original name of marvel comics he's
the one who hired a young stan lee jack kirby all
those classic era marvel creatives that you know
then later the company changed his name a couple
times eventually changing it to marvel comics
they've used the martin goodman marvel comics
productions easter egg a couple times in the
marvel universe they used it during moon knight
too when they're revealing the true origin of the
stephen grant persona that he was a character in a
fictional movie called tomb busters the production
company of that movie on the poster was listed as
timely atlas productions that was another easter
egg for martin goodman's timely comics but what
happened is is it started out as timely comics
then in the 1950s they changed their name to atlas
comics then after that they changed their name to
marvel comics the next easter egg is that movie
the kingo made in the 1970s and a lot of you will
probably remember this movie from the eternals
movie like they represented in a couple different
marvel movies if you remember kingo's backstory
he was with sprite until he left her in macedonia
and went to india to become a bollywood movie
star the first real big movie that he starred
in later in the timeline was son of suraj and that
is the poster that you're seeing on this wall here
and at the time he was pretending to be his great
great grandfather and what would happen is that
he would just disappear after a little while and
resurface as that person's son and then after a
certain amount of time had passed by he'd do the
same thing again and again until eventually you
get the kingdom that you see today he joked that
his assistant karoon came along and thought that
he was a vampire when he started to notice that
he would not age actually when we first met he
thought i was a vampire and he tried to stake me
through the heart i've apologized so many times
not quite enough times very close though i'll
let you know we'll see actual vampires in the
mcu during the blade movie next year or the year
after that depending on when they finish filming
it there are a couple other easter eggs with
these other movie posters too but some of these
are posters from movies that were released in real
life so i think the events of this episode this
movie released that they're going to this theater
is taking place during the year 1974 in the mcu
because all these movies are from posters from
movies that were released in 1974. like this is
the real poster for a movie called airport 1975.
this is a poster for a movie called earthquake
this is a poster for the real life love
bug sequel called herbie rides again which
was released by disney in 1974 so i think that
confirms that kingo's son of suresh movie that
his great great grandfather supposedly made even
though it was real kingo was also released in 1974
the next big easter egg is on another poster for
a movie called phone ranger who yes as ridiculous
as that sounds is another actual marvel character
from the comics in the comics phone ranger was a
character named a.g bell like bell phone systems
that was an actual phone company he started out
as a telephone repairman who was sent to fix a
phone that unknown to anyone was actually acting
as a prison for a small race of aliens known as
the celta's a.g bell wound up using the technology
that the alien race left in the phone replicating
it and used it to give himself the power to tap
into any communications technology using that
power to become a superhero fighting crime but
like his actual costume kind of looks like a phone
person the star of that movie though is charles
theobald the only reference and connection i could
think to marvel comics is a brigadier theobold
inky blot in the comics who was a supporting
character from excalibur who has ties to fy6
but if you look here the production company
for this phone ranger movie is also goodman
productions but because thor love and thunder is
coming out this week a lot of you asking is loki
in thor love and thunder or why is he not in thor
love and thunder because taco bell td even chris
hemsworth even tom hiddleston have said that
loki is not supposed to be in the movie thor
love and thunder isn't meant to be a multiverse
movie in the way that doctor strange 2 was or
the way that loki season 1 or even loki season 2
is or even ant-man 3. issues meant to take place
in the main mcu universe and is more about the
different pantheons of gods in the mcu so even
though it's like a really big story in scope it's
a little more self-contained that you don't get
into many many alternate universes during the
movie like just this one particular mcu universe
and they just said that they'd played out a lot
of that original loki and thor story like the
brotherly story so maybe we'll see them together
in the future but the funny thing recently is that
taika waititi actually gave his pitch for thor
5 for like the next movie in the thor franchise
and it did involve a version of tom hiddleston and
then that'll be the next thor film for me because
a challenge for me is then to make something to
make them love it you know thor okay thor and a
buddy on a road trip to vegas fully closed in
winter christmas oh christmas okay i've got it
thor chris a chris christmas two christmas chris
pratt and thor oh my god guys take this down
star-lord thor road trip movie christmas they've
got to get to thomas house for christmas so his
joke idea for thor 5 there is a christmas road
trip movie with chris pratt and chris hemsworth
star-lord and thor on a road trip to tom's house
and he's talking about tom hiddleston as in loki's
house they are actually doing a christmas
special this year but it's a guardians of the
galaxy christmas special they're just calling it
the guardians of the galaxy holiday special it's
meant to be a live-action prequel to guardians
of the galaxy 3 to explain what happens with
the guardians after they leave in thor love and
thunder but before the events of guardians of the
galaxy 3 pick up but if you have any big questions
about loki season 2 or you spotted any easter eggs
in these brand new scenes that i didn't talk about
in the video just write them below in the comments
my thor love and thunder review video will post
tomorrow so be sure to enable alerts so you don't
miss that in all my full post credit scene videos
easter eggs breakdown of the entire movie we'll
start posting later this week after the movie
actually comes out everyone click here for my
brand new black panther 2 namor first look
and first look at some of the other really
big characters during the movie and what's going
on and click here for my new thor love and thunder
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!